you
ladies of June please stand and welcome
the faculty and graduates of the class
of 2010
you
good afternoon it feels just magnificent
to stand before you remarkable men and
women to celebrate the culmination of
your scholarly accomplishments this is
one of my most rewarding experiences as
dean of students that is extending my
warmest proudest congratulations to you
all the class of 2010
and you may be seated and also
congratulations to the families and
friends who have supported you through
the past years of your program at ciba
and are here today to share in our joy
many people have shaped your experiences
at sepa and none have been more
important than our world-renowned
faculty please let's applaud our faculty
as well
they have challenged you in numerous
ways many of which I know about because
you have come to my office to discuss
them but in ways leading you to new
discoveries about your academic
discipline and hopefully your inner self
and capabilities I would now like to
introduce you to Dean John Coatsworth
whose vision and leadership has created
a stronger community at sefa it is which
is committed to the discovery of new
knowledge and applying it toward the
betterment of society in this rapidly
changing world I am honored for you to
meet Dean cotesworth Dean of the School
of International and public affairs and
professor of history and International
and public affairs Dean Coatsworth
Thank You Cassandra on behalf of the
University I would like to extend the
warmest of welcomes to every one of the
733 members of the CEPA class of 2010
and the same warm welcome to the members
of our faculty who taught them and
learned from them to our distinguished
guests and do the families and friends
our graduates have counted on for
support and encouragement this afternoon
we gather to honor the achievements of
some of the most remarkable people you
will ever meet they will soon join
16,000 sefa alumni working in 155
countries whose main goal in their
incredibly diverse ways is to make our
planet more fit for human habitation
nothing could be more important or more
urgent than the work of the members of
Cephas class of 2010 that work they will
soon be doing on behalf of us all cephas
mission is to Train professionals to
confront the world's problems with
knowledge and skills second to none and
as you know as all of you know and sepa
graduates know in excruciating detail
the world is still full of problems that
need fixing the problems we face from
global recession and violent conflict to
climate change and humanitarian
disasters cannot be solved by knowledge
and zeal alone and skill alone even when
they are wedded to the kind of zeal for
serving the public good that sepa
students have in such abundance but they
can be addressed and even solved more
quickly more efficiently more
effectively with seatback graduates
working on the 16,000 sepa alumni I just
mentioned in clue
the former Foreign Minister of Mexico
and a former US Secretary of State the
public advocate of the city of New York
NBC's White House correspondent the
Middle East advocacy director for Human
Rights Watch the chairman of China's sun
TV of new york state senator from
brooklyn and the finance ministers of
lithuania and mongolia the cold head of
the co-head of global mergers and
acquisitions of deutsche bank the budget
director of dreaded IRS and two Pulitzer
Prize winners in the last three years
wherever there's good work to be done
you can sure you can be sure there will
be a sepa graduate ready to do it and do
it well as the members of Cephas class
of 2010 depart Columbia for new lives
scattered across the globe sepa itself
is beginning a new era in its history in
2015 if all goes according to plan we
will move to a spectacular new building
just three blocks from where we are now
a building with plenty of elevators and
a real cafeteria
in the meantime the school has joined
the ranks of Columbia's great and
independently self-governing
professional schools implemented a new
curriculum this past fall and continues
to play a key role in the accelerating
globalization of Columbia University and
its transformation from us University
with an international reputation to into
a truly global institution sepa will
also raise enormous sums of money to
make this all possible no graduate of
the school no matter how far away will
ever again be safe from the outstretched
hands and relentless email reminders of
Cephas fundraising department the class
of 2010 is off to a great start with a
wonderful class gift for Cephas ever
needy fellowship fun thank you before
introducing our commencement speaker I
would like to acknowledge the presence
of a number of Cephas distinguished
faculty at an awards luncheon earlier
today sepa recognized the recipients of
the 2010 distinguished teaching awards
professors Paola valenti and Francisco
Rivera Bacchus I would ask them
and in your program books you will see
the names and of the awardees who
received a number of student prizes at
that same commencement lunch a short
time ago those of you or a present all
of you are present the citations and the
names of the prize winners are in your
program our graduation speaker today is
Vikram funded president and chief
operating officer of Citigroup a global
bank that could have failed in 2008
Vikram was born in India in the city of
Nagpur the city of oranges once called
the heart of India by java la la neige
drew the country's first Prime Minister
nagpur is now a city of two and a half
million lies in the northeast corner of
the Indian state of maharashtra once the
heart of the Maratha Empire a Hindu
state rested from mogul rule in the 17th
century that extended over more than
half the territory of modern India
reduced in size by dynastic Wars the
self-governing kingdom of Nagpur was the
last of the Indian princely states to
fall under British rule in 1853 Vikram
Pandit was born into a prosperous
Brahmin family who sent their bright Sun
to the Darcy youth assembly high school
in a prosperous suburb of Mumbai he was
not only bright but in patient leaping
from Mumbai to the new to New York in a
flash and entering Columbia at a mere 16
years of age and he liked Columbia so
much that he began collecting degrees at
a furious pace a BS in 1976 and ms and
electoral electrical engineering the
next year and a PhD in finance and
86 all told he must have devoted the
better part of a decade and a half to
becoming a triple degree Columbia
alumnus and now he's back for even more
punishment as a member of the Columbia
Board of Trustees like most newly minted
phd's Vikram set out to become a
professor landing his first good job at
Indiana University in bucolic
Bloomington it did not take him long to
begin planning his escape back in New
York after what his official biography
describes as a short stint in Indiana he
launched his wall street career at
Morgan Stanley where he spent the next
20 years he left Morgan Stanley at the
top of his game to found a new hedge
fund hedge fund known as old partners
old lane partners in 2006 in 2007
Citigroup bought old lane partners or so
it seemed at the time actually it was
Vikram who took over Citigroup but he
did so with just just as the subprime
crisis and then the financial meltdown
hit Wall Street Vikram Pandit became
president and CEO of Citigroup on
December 11-2 2007 and immediately
lowered his salary to one dollar a year
for the duration of the crisis under his
leadership Citigroup changed course
began shedding unneeded assets received
and then paid back 45 billion dollars in
government bailout funds and has just
returned to profitability as a leaner
and more effective global bank in the
past two years Vikram has repeatedly and
thoughtfully called for better and
stronger regulation of financial markets
more effective consumer protection and
greater transparency and accountability
in the financial services sector I am
delighted now to invite Victor man
it to address cephas class of 2010
Thank You Dean cotesworth for that kind
in rather complete introduction good
afternoon distinguished faculty parents
family friends and the class of 2010
congratulations on your graduation I'm
honored to return to campus to be part
of this very special occasion now some
of you may be surprised but bankers
don't often get invited to speak that is
unless they're in front of Congress so I
do know that the invitation for me to
speak here today stirred up some
controversy and I think that's a healthy
sign I would be surprised even
disappointed if some of the most intense
debate and criticism of the financial
industry were not coming from this
university the Columbia I experience was
always that way so let me start by
acknowledging that Americans have the
right to be angry about the financial
crisis people should question the
financial system and those who run it
the severe impact of the financial
crisis demonstrates that even in the
21st century we have not learned how to
achieve a healthy balance between
private economic power and public
interest of course we need significant
change we need to hit the reset button
and get society working once again for
the common interest we cannot live
without the financial system but we do
not have to accept it successes cephas
purpose is to help solve the toughest
public policy dilemmas your education
here equips you to understand how
private economic power and public
interest can coalesce or clash how the
intersection of the two can either be
destructive or a constructive force in
America
and around the world so whether you go
from seaport to the public sector or the
private sector your broad education has
prepared you to play a very special role
as we hit the reset button you're
entering the workplace at an
extraordinary time and I must compliment
you on your sense of timing I've got to
admit I wouldn't have minded spending
the last two years in school let me be
clear there are significant challenges
ahead of us but we have the ability to
embark on a cycle of prosperity full of
opportunity for you but that requires
society to work for common interests
with common goals and that is why I
wanted to speak with you today the
effects of financial crisis are still
very much with us the crisis has
generated fear and uncertainty it has
also been a humbling experience for the
developed nation including our own with
ten percent unemployment there are
questions about where jobs and growth
are going to come from with a 1.3
trillion dollar deficit there are
significant questions on the
sustainability of current fiscal and
monetary policies and there are some who
question capitalism doubt the
competitive strength of our country and
fewer what lies ahead for the u.s. in a
dramatically changing global order from
where I sit however I cannot help but be
optimistic the 200-year history of my
bank has stretched through every
financial crisis in America since the
war of 1812 entrepreneurship and
creativity have propelled America for
over 200 years and if you look at US
economic history every time there's a
crisis there's a breakthrough of new
businesses new models new growth so from
all of that plus my own training
experience I have a firm conviction that
America has the ability to embark on
era of growth a new beginning in the US
Capitol finds its way to the right
places fast we make capital work quickly
and efficiently the public and private
sectors have repeatedly been able to
work together to connect talented people
with opportunities and to connect
capital with entrepreneurs to drive
economic regeneration time and time
again that's what has given birth to the
Google's of the world and improved life
for millions this has been America's
magic formula but keep in mind it is no
longer America's secret we need to
remember too that the u.s. generates
approximately twenty-three percent of
global economic activity and therefore
addressing us growth is necessary to
promote growth around the world so again
whether you go to an NGO the public
sector or private enterprise we have a
common goal to preserve and enhance the
creativity of American economic
ingenuity while controlling it successes
in effect letting America's magic
formula work once again but with full
incorporation of the expensive lessons
learned from the crisis as we debate
policy as we reinvent the structure and
governance of our economy we must
preserve and re-energize our model of
growth that is in society's common
interest so what does it take I believe
there are three critical dynamics that
must operate together first we must fix
the financial system second we've got to
accept the need for America to compete
in a new global order and third we must
have a culture or responsibility first
the financial system
we need a financial system that works a
financial system that returns to its
basic role of supporting and driving the
economy America's growth and vitality
plus its capacity to improve people's
lives depends on it a healthy financial
system is absolutely indispensable to
generate capital and to move it
efficiently to entrepreneurs who creates
will create jobs and growth that benefit
everyone without comprehensive financial
reform there's little hope our markets
can serve the common good now I've been
very outspoken about this and I believe
in several principles to help restore
the trust in our system I believe bank
should be banks focused on serving
clients I believe we must have a level
playing field the same rules for
everybody we should end once and for all
the phenomena of too big to fail we need
a strong federal consumer authority to
protect consumer interests and most
importantly we need real transparency
into financial transactions to
strengthen our system for natural checks
and balances think about this in our age
of Facebook and Twitter you can easily
learn the details of your neighbors
personal life but virtually nothing
about a hundred million dollar market
moving trade in triple-a corporate bonds
there's something fundamentally out of
whack with that picture technology is a
great equalizer and we should be using
it to make crucial financial information
available not hidden behind firewalls
second America's need to compete in the
new global order thinking about
America's role in the global economy
requires simple first steps for instance
we can no longer define common interest
in national terms alone in fact we
cannot afford not to define it in global
terms economic cycles and systemic
failures have profound fast-moving
global consequences and the u.s. is both
their transmitter and receptor of these
consequences to act in accordance with
global realities also means we have to
ensure us global competitiveness and
promote our export economy this implies
globally competitive industrial policies
tax policies and energy policies the
growing urban middle class and the
emerging economies represent an
important export market for our
companies and of course America must
remain the world's best place for the
world's best talent to be our
universities and borders must remain
open and attract the world's best minds
this need is a very special one to me as
Dean cotesworth just talked about I came
to the United States almost four decades
ago I received a great education was
able to pursue professional success and
most importantly my children have those
same opportunities that's only before
because our nation's policies have
reflected what America has long stood
for now is not the time to retrench in
this vital area and third a culture of
responsibility America came to believe
in the existence of a bottomless pool of
credit we developed an addiction to
consumption in debt both were
intoxicated even to some of the
country's best financial minds together
consumption and debt became a foundation
of quicksand for the American success
story as we can see with twenty-twenty
hindsight neither individuals nor
institutions behaved responsibly
preneur ship and creativity were
distorted to serve selfish ends with no
understanding of or regard for their
impact on society self-interest
unapologetically trumped public interest
to promote responsibility we do need
legal and regulatory reform but the 21st
century has once again Illustrated that
there is no ironclad correlation between
the enactment of more regulations and
the end of major financial crisis smart
people with new technologies can always
find a way around the letter of the law
we have no choice but to learn how to
internalize a strong sense of
responsibility in both individuals and
institutions that is the surest way of
to change behavior and will not make the
u.s. model immune to periodic excesses
however it can mitigate their frequency
and severity but that means we must have
a new commitment to responsibility in
our personal lives a commitment of
disciplined management of spending and
saving in government a commitment to cut
deficits support investment and act
swiftly and decisively on critical
priorities right like energy policy and
in private instead of private sector
institutions like mine a true commitment
to act in the common interest I'll speak
for one institution we ask ourselves
three questions constantly do our
actions create economic value are we
working for customers interests are our
actions systemically responsible both in
the US and globally the answers to all
three questions must be yes I have
pledged to hold myself accountable for
making sure we ask the questions that
lead to the right decisions
they're the foundation of a change in
culture I call responsible finance but
cultural change is easier to proclaim
than to live up to every day there are
intense pressures in the financial
industry from competitors shareholders
and the large sums of money with which
we are interested similarly in public
service there are pressures to enact
policies because of political compulsion
rather than true concern for common
interest such pressures and in private
and public sectors demand never-ending
examination of what serves the common
good the relentless questioning of what
we're doing and how we're doing it
people have to speak up and act
resolutely that takes courage and
leadership and this may be the most
difficult requirement of all when I left
Columbia I had no idea that training and
engineering or economics would lead me
to questions a culture or responsible
behavior I started out not knowing
exactly what I would do Plato once said
the direction in which education starts
a man will determine his future in life
like you I left Columbia with a great
education from a great University
knowing what I like to do and I've
plunged into it passionately and since
then I've always felt I'm continuing my
education from my own experiences with
America Columbia and the industry I
believe your education at sepa has
superbly prepared you to tackle one of
our most important priorities how to
unleash all that is creative and good in
the American economic model while
raining in its worst impulses this is a
challenge of enormous consequences it
cuts across every facet of American life
indeed how we address it will affect the
entire world but it is also our greatest
opportunity as I said before I can't
help but be optimistic about the future
and all i have to do is look at all of
you out there to know we have what it
takes i know you have the knowledge the
leadership and the courage to confront
this historic challenge and take
advantage of its many opportunities and
i expect to come back here say in about
20 years or so and hear one of you tell
the graduates of sepa about the great
progress your classmate and shaping a
world where private economic power
serves the common good so thank you for
inviting me to speak today
congratulations again on your graduation
please accept my very best wishes in all
that you do from this day forward thank
you
thank you very much Vikram the time has
now come to recognize one by one the 733
members of Cephas class of 2010 some of
you may already have begun to calculate
how it might be possible to grab a
camera leap from your seat and race
toward the front of the church timing
your move with such precision that you
arrive at your destination just as your
graduates name is called out happily
such calculations are entirely
unnecessary because see PES
photographers will be taking fishville
official commencement photos of each of
the 733 memorable moments that are about
to occur so even though the spirit may
move you please don't race forward to
take photos and now I am pleased to
begin the price by introducing professor
John mutter director of Graduate Studies
who will present the candidates for the
PhD in sustainable development Dean
Coatsworth assembled members of the
faculty and students it's my very very
great pleasure to present to you those
who have qualified for the degree of the
PhD in sustainable development in doing
so this year they have increased the
number of graduates of this program
five-hole from one to five
while they are rare in their numbers
that will soon change but they are not
rare in their scholarly distinction and
that will never change two of them have
been able to come and allow you to
present them their degrees to others are
unable to make it those who are unable
to make it are Jessica bonds who
presented her dissertation on governing
floor the politics of water distribution
and use in Egypt and Lily partial we
presented her dissertation in the local
geography of energy demand case studies
from the United States and Kenya those
who have been able to make it include
Margaret McLeod who presented her
dissertation on essays and human capital
formation in sustainable development
Jose re whaler who presented his
dissertation on journeys towards
sustainable development policy
entrepreneurs and the rise of the green
state and Chile and Peru
thank you John now I am pleased to
present professor stephen cohen who will
present the candidates for master's of
Public Administration in environmental
science and policy Thank You Dean I'm
delighted to do that to introduce our
fabulous graduates starting with Cody I
CLE
salam al qasimi
Matthew Baron Adam bat Nick Duritz
blakeslee Dina Valachi Kevin Burns Tina
cow the nicole chan
Caitlin cleaver Angela crone Laura
croushore Sylvia Liana cruise Thiago de
valdes pacheco Sarah freiburg Brian
Goldblatt Sarah Hall Christopher Hawkins
elizabeth clare ho Ashley Holmes
Jennifer holzer Rebecca Hudson Ryan
Jackson Catherine John Jill que no Dana
kaplan Erica kev early
Laura Kelly Marcus Kinney Elizabeth
LaBarbera April lee jung woo lee james
levine Justin mankin now manami Cullen
new mom Daniel Newman Cara peace
Karen Perlmutter lawn fawn Connor
Phillips Kelly Proctor Catherine cruets
Michael Roush Catherine Rodriguez Yasmin
Rizzo Kowski Mary Margaret's a bungee
Tamar sanusi Bradley schallert Daniel
Shapiro Genevieve Slocum Brett summer
Meyer a myth srivastava Brittany Stein
guard Zachary sue Tilly Cameron
thorstenson Deborah T sin
on a Wang Marguerite Weber Lonnie wild
Cheryl Wilson Leo Wilson megan wilson
Katie whoo and last but not least
Catherine worden
now I am pleased to introduce William
Emmett adjunct professor and executive
director of the picker Center for
executive education who will present the
candidates for the executive masters of
public administration Thank You Dean
pleased to present the EMP a graduates a
very special group particularly in light
of the fact that they completed their
group degree most of them in the same
two years as the full time students but
we're all working full time so we'll
begin with bashira abdus sabur georgina
angeles mo met Barry at yannick Kristin
Barlow
Joseph barreto Janelle verdict Maria
Campos Stephanie Chang John dandelo
Elizabeth to me see Leonardo Fernandez
tracy foster Sarah fraunhofer Andrew
fuller Nicole gallant Christina gets
Wendy Jerome arena Koufos shamsul haque
Brian Heath Judith Hernandez Melissa
Hernandez Vargas Martin Howard Augustine
Noel cane sir on Lee Andrew McFall
Claire Medina salut Marin a gory mukerji
Sofia nadja fee Stephen numark nicole
ogden Lou Ann Parker Catherine / to
coalesce Alicia renmin Martinez Phillip
Ritz
vilma Rivera Gomez jeffer rizvi jos
Rosado fight Sadiq
ryan sandberg thomas smith
turlock Smith is ur top choo-choo glue
Megan Torres William Brendan Berg Ida
Wayne shell cools lei wang jin young un
chen qi zhao and last but not least
Aaron Miller
now let me present I took professor
arvinder kaskus who will introduce to
you the candidates for master's of
Public Administration in economic policy
management
Thank You Dean coaster it's my honor to
introduce the peplum class of 2010
starting with Iman alum Aldean nada al
himala we Alejandro De Aza Valentina
hacerlo junk jung-bae the Hooda ba
Ibrahim Panguna panita bra mucci Lydia
boob Anya Catalina Castillo Kishan Troy
Samantha channel
they are three school bus
karoliina tirana uncle
John bricklin Dwyer fatima al career a
humani alejandro escandon galcen Georgie
Matthew hogben
Khloe kwang kyu twitchy ito silky to
Vectren cali bakov rathi slough
korchinsky Makoto Kusanagi Michael lon
Samuel the winter ramin mask on Madonna
boomp a Mickey junko Miyasaki
muhammad jamil Nasir salmon / de mer
Egor filipenko Fernando pimentel by
roots action and Andy oh do Sally who
Peter son
Paul Scott
Walker a mod shake
yasuhiro Tanaka
Dorn Robert Townsend why hung chang
asuka tsuboi key for say velocity key
sharing one world
and last but not least Chung Chung John
congratulations peplum class of 2010
now I'm pleased to introduce professor
Robert Lieberman vice dean for academic
affairs who will present the candidates
for master's in public administration
Thank You Dean cotesworth I'm very proud
to salute the 2010 mpa class beginning
with anthony advincula cake oh I kawa
Alyosha far on my essa al thani Adriana
armenta mere nutella James Baker got'em
Bastian Radhika batra Sandra melanda
Jeremy middle Andrew door Maria Paula
carvajal Sangha cherry ann marie
coalfield Kristen melon Cecily
David Karen Davies Elia dela Cruz Toledo
Deborah Del Mar anessa Diaz Buddha Lars
dingman so long dude Hillary Ellison
Jacqueline Escobar
rubenesque ahead Sebastian Eugene ronita
folic William Fadden Nerissa to
Fukushima Monica Gadkari paola Garcia
Gina's 19 ego pina need a tow hakamada
Tommy Hinds song one Hong Steven horn
Toby Howard nuria ichikawa Harris edit
area FISA inayat Katerina izumo Florian
Jansen Thiago trucking Ashley callous
routes Illya come Lonnie re come ready
Madonna ken Donna on jump led Easter
Archon Saleem Khan Anjali Khurana
wooden sick Kim Julie climb iva kleinova
go kobayashi Morgan corn and wreak a
cool Gonzales long Ling loud une melee
Christina less Chuck Don Lin
Stephen little and friend
leila mulla Rachel jose antonio martinez
haro Libby McArdle Michael makassar
Catherine Miller Nelson Monroe Joseph
pool houses Caroline looky row z nuts
nazir Daisuke nishino
Ambrosio and singly barros carry O'Neill
re on Ortiz marrufo Alexander obvious
Emily and Pat Rita Baracus Daniel Perez
Roberto pesca de Vargas Lauren casa
monica p aashiq vanessa portillo Revati
prasad
horse khurana Sidra raima Alec rieger
David Rogovin Gustavo seguir Meza Pablo
Salazar Lopez rakia Sammy Melissa sands
Sandra shark Aaron Seibert abhi baat
ishani Mahama marina sport Krista Silva
Jones sukadeva nunchaku Chaka he day
sawada sanjayan shrikant ahh Maurice
Stanford yo hey takashima hero michi
tsuchida machi tsuchida toca Tehran can
we go
Marco Velarde Bravo Giselle rosana
Velasquez Gutierrez Karen via fauna
Andrea vivaro mio washes ooh Emma Webber
andrea wong pen on sri zhang yi yao zhi
zhen Nicholas O'Brien and tomo Yuki
amore congratulations to the NPA class
of 2010
now I'd like to introduce again
associate dean Cassandra Simmons who
will present the students receiving the
Masters of international
erica ikeda al-thani jassim Michelle
Allen son Almeida Abdul Hossein Amini
Alex an itch Frank and a sworn Nettie
Sarah Gabby apollon Zachary Arnie Angela
Arthur Jennifer at anas Oscar jennie-o
anahi a yalla ya coochie Martin back far
off William by ramyun
chiefly banta yahoo
Alan bar Mariana Barrera piak Antonio
Barroso Valeska Alessandro bartolini
Jessica bartolini innocent bosch cereal
Buffy's not wha doc is Kareem Bennett
Sarah Bieber Kevin bill Sarah bishop
kelly bishop Kate brick Alexander boosie
Jang goon goon golonka crystal Carol
Alyssa casado megan casey matt metallic
jump kanchan Emily Chang Nicholas Cheng
Oh Marchetta Karina says yay juancho
Ruby joy-giving chua Kristen Coco Maria
Cortez push andrew kramer michael
creighton a mika singh savi maria
gabriela da rocha oliveira Mohini dad
Darcy dacosta Jennifer Davis Olympia the
castro if the LaMotta karroubi Christian
Tinkler Audrey the serato salad here
with me let me try ever I kasto she
Jamie Doherty Benjamin doh Douglas
Dawson katarzyna Duda Allen tool AV
Petra dune Elizabeth Edelstein mera kya
Tony a keyword
sammy al safi when L would Rebecca angle
holy hands in barstow receipt adil Amir
as rocky azhar Pablo Espinel yuan Fang
Parker fail Dane Fisher Benjamin Flossie
William Freeland Gwyneth fries Anna
froome's Alexander golf key arena gams
case again arm indium Maria geelani
selec Heather Gilmartin Alex Kiran go do
Kristina Gomes maritza Gonzalez John
Goodman Nora Gordon Talia Garuda's money
Guerrero evgenia kasilof and Antonia
harbor Cara haberman
Katherine Higgins zubayr Hakim Abdul
lucky coloquei seguerra hams iva jin han
how Harper Vanessa drew hard Olga
Hartman Rebecca Hickok Jessica hemphill
kyle henderson Michael Hendley ileana
hit be singhji humor Jonathan Hawks Todd
soup Johan Matthew Horner michael wong
john hughes Joshua Hanukkah shabnam hook
Gabriela yankoo angel in drove oh hi
badal Ismail Omar Nikolas yeah girl
Michael Jagger's Rudolph Justin Johnson
whom
who knew Hyo Jeong Jeong aaron King Albu
nakuru khushi Omar kasra we k Kastner
Andrew Kissinger Tiffany con Johan
Torabi ethnic him Jin ho Kim me hey Kim
Patrick Kim Lauren Klein Caroline closer
Jeffrey Clarke
so Chuck coach kristin kebbel Gabriel
collar Derek Julia cook very coppleson
Stefan kobani David Kovich Sabine
rachman Karina lakowicz Carmilla lelani
karina clock you bitch
sincerely Diana jung kyung lee stephanie
lee julienne leveque Fiona function Lee
Emma linguists Joshua law Matthew locust
Natalie Luna to honda sonia lutra aditi
mahendru Gloria magnet Nishad much
madara sama Makino sahil mana kiya
Danielle maniscalco Elizabeth Marcelo
Gregoire Masato Clara Martinez to Col
James McGill st anomaly sanaz Lamar
siddiqui soon i eat miss Finn
Murray Mets Charlotte Mayor and Carolyn
michelly and missionary Heather Miller
John Miller sanket mystery Sarah meet
Wally mana magaca miyawaki Matthew Moore
Deborah Mott was key Lyle Morris two-way
move David milani Paloma munoz Stephen
Murphy kavita near room in 80 deepika
nourish even junko narimasu
Cody nascimento Farah darkness Ali
Nicholas Nadine wha mom Maurice and I
live edita nehru Emily Nelson Micheline
tyler nelson a detainee come simran
necks mau no gawa nasty nordstrom shiori
okazaki victoria ocoee Robert ah ah yes
yes Victoria career Robert owner a mean
or not
Leah Ortiz de barros mark Osmonds Maya
Polly Magdalena pompeo Shruti pan till
hopin for sino parodies Dominique Perez
k Duke park Marta passerini Ellen pola
Lara pedrini Tom talents milagros
Peralta vanoza pereira Bravo julissa
Perez Carlos Perez Diaz SETI SETI
somehow Petros
rohana pandas Albert Philip limas Annie
porta Gary poses Elena profits ki-mata
rahman Estelle Raimundo boss rush rush
rotana bitch Anna Anna Lisa pamela rae
is Herrera Veronica rock array Diana
Rodriguez angel Rosales hey d rose be
Beth Rosen Emmanuel rural delevingne
Jessica rush yo yo nigga the manual no
Nathaniel Rutledge morale basically ever
annoy a tron sadiq ova souvik saha rio
cycle ahmed salim divya sama
jenison King yasuhiro sasayama Eva
savage Evelyn scared Amanda skier and
Susie jennifer scott Rachel Sirota
nishant shah monica sharma
why he'd she
lennis ml li Yu Chang Stephen Sherman
Aisha chef Stephanie shore Michael
seaboard bread Simon Bradley scootin
Tracy's Lego Brian Smith dancer bhavik
whale and soon Gerald's thing Caroline
Stauffer Eric Stefan
Mary Ann ston Carla see shouting tang
Carla see shouting tang Christopher
angry Jenny Taylor Natasha Taylor Lyra
Louise tellson the ante on Aaron teams
Christina tippmann Ian top man jacket on
Tony took her to Tran Carlos to Hilo
liat rozinsky she shout Chang Josephine
to melayu Alana to me know Monique to
his anger on Ebola Nikolas to yapchi
hi-yah cogida Andrew woman's McHale
husband Michael vice-like Patrick
Valentino
Alberto Valverde Gregory vandeven Dario
blue cheese Sebastian bone reward pratip
ha hoopa Lori mark one maangchi one hole
in one mark Weingarten Christina wig
Davina would Stephanie would our Alisa
right Garrett right Garrett right
in a union that that has AIDS Serani
xiamen Alejandro zamorano cadavid Olga
Zaretsky Savannah Zepeda Lauren Ziggler
Sarah Jory atalaya bar Matthew jalali
we have come as swiftly as we could to
the end of our graduation ceremony
please remain seated for the recessional
so that the graduates and the faculty
can depart in good order and with as
much solemnity as we can muster the
audience will exit through different set
of doors to present prevent congestion
but rest assured that your graduate will
find you outside please watch for
traffic try to keep out of the street
hope there's one more item on our agenda
which I don't want to forget and almost
did associate dean Cassandra Simmons
will introduce the student speakers
I would like to call to the stage please
Alec obvious who is the MPA co-president
for sebasa and also William for ramen
please come forward
both Alec and William have distinguished
themselves over the past two years and
have served as co-chairs of the student
organization it is cephas tradition that
the co-chairs will address the class
individually and we will start with Alec
please thank you
congratulations to the class of 2010 and
a special welcome special welcome to
those who long distances to be here with
us today these days these days that's an
achievement in and of itself I've been
asked to keep my remarks short so I'll
try and get straight to the point like
everyone else here I've spent some time
these past few weeks asking myself the
questions that soon-to-be graduates
typically ask what exactly have I
learned here was it worth it would I do
it over again I can't stand up here and
say in all honesty that this was a
perfect experience and nor should i
expect it to have been but there were
certainly aspects to the school that I
was frustrated with like the uninstalled
coffee machine on the fourth floor and
that printer that always seemed to break
down five minutes before a paper was due
but I would say that my frustrations are
relatively minor and that on the whole
it has been a wonderful meaningful
experience what we have here is an
exceptional school that attracts an
incredibly talented and accomplished
students at no other school would you
get the diversity that you find at sefa
with every religion race profession that
you could you can think of represented
here what makes sepa exceptional though
is the commitment held by its students
to improving the world in whatever field
or specialty they have chosen to pursue
be it in security Human Rights economics
energy environment media or development
the school wouldn't be what it is
without the phenomenal faculty that it
has and I'd like to thank some of the
great teachers that have had the
opportunity to study with in particular
professor Jarrett Anna
professor Morgan professor Rob and
professor McLean the question that keeps
coming up in my mind was whether this
was worth it and frankly we can't answer
that today we've all made very large
investments in sefa in terms of money
time and energy and at the risk of
sounding like the corporate finance ta
that I am I would say that we have to
ask ourselves what the return on our
investment will be you can say well it
will pay off to the extent that the CEPA
education continues to be recognized
throughout the world as being a valuable
good or a valuable asset in this case
the responsibility rests with sefa to
build its reputation and to continue to
attract the best students in the world
at the same time it's our job to join
the workforce and to show our future
employers and colleagues that sepa does
really represent the best of the best
but this I think is a rather narrow
interpretation of what I meant more
importantly this investment will pay off
in so far as we use what we've learned
here to enrich our lives and the lives
of others can we use the knowledge the
skills the connections and friendships
that we've formed over the past two
years to make some sort of positive
meaningful contribution to the world I
should hope so but we'll see what I can
say is that given all of the challenges
that the world faces from global warming
the fallout from the reckless and
irresponsible actions of the financial
industry through the threat of radical
Islam that probably hasn't better better
time in the past 60 years to enter into
the field of public policy many of the
world's problems today are global in
scale so those of us with
internationalist perspectives have an
important advantage luckily for us our
timing has been pretty spot-on and now
more than ever the world needs people
like us to try and set things straight
in conclusion I would remind you that
sefa took a gamble on us a few years ago
of all the applications they
see they said you know what these guys
have what it takes to make a difference
so now it's time to deliver on those
expectations with that I'll say good
luck Godspeed and be sure to keep in
touch
all right folks we made it
first and foremost I want to thank you
for allowing me to be your m.i.a class
president over the past year I really
appreciate that honor let me get started
as the brochures promised seba turned
out to be a pretty unique place one
where students from all over the world
came to study and to exchange the
different perspectives in relative peace
and with respect but that's not the only
reason that I thought see if it was a
great place so far as I'm concerned we
went to the best school at Columbia
University who cares that other schools
had fancy furniture and well lit
libraries and coffee machines but they
didn't have we're sepa students except
for the dual degrees and the seat and
the students at sea for when the what
made this place great we're a unique
bunch we have parties networking happy
hours a massive barbecue with a moon
drum fraternal get-togethers on the 6th
floor to put it lightly and a comedy
show produced wholly by students that is
so popular that it sold out in 30
minutes speaking of parties I want to
give a quick thank you to the NYPD for
remaining steadfast in their commitment
to their mantra of courtesy
professionalism and respect
graduate student parties are a safer
place because of you in all there isn't
anybody that can say that they had this
much fun getting a master's degree yet
yet yet we found time to read 3,000
pages for dr. Betts class we toiled to
the end of the semester on capstone
projects we wrote hundreds of pages of
supremely eloquent essays and we spent
the daylight hours on the weekends
drawing so many supply and demand graphs
that it would make an economist cry and
it probably did and in the process we
became friends we went to dinners
together
it's not all fun and games we shared our
thoughts with one another we hugged each
other and we took trips together and in
the process we became family then we
celebrated holidays together we took
care of each other in times of need we
left and we cry and in the process we
came to love each other and today we're
here to celebrate one more time those
memories we created over the past two
years and we're here to celebrate those
people sitting next to us right now who
left an indelible mark on our hearts and
whom will never forget we had left our
families wherever we came from and we
found another one at sepa and to those
family members that we left behind some
of whom are here some of whom are back
home and some of whom are no longer with
us I think I speak for all the graduates
when I say that we are grateful to have
you in our lives
as individualistic and independent as we
may be we all made it here in some way
because of the family and friends we
have known throughout our lives and for
many of us this accomplishment would not
have been possible without the
incredible support and understanding of
the parents siblings spouses and
children who supported us in our
decision to come to sepa and as I give
banks as I give thanks to all of our
family members here I would like to give
thanks to my family as well to my mother
were forced to smile every time I left
home because she knew I couldn't bear to
see her cry to my father who made every
sacrifice without a thought or doubt so
that I may achieve whatever I aspire to
tell my cousin yet Otto who always had
more faith in me than I did in myself to
my brother's head huntin patrick who put
up with me all these years the hardest
part about me being in New York City was
being away from the two of you and I
love you more than you can imagine and
thanks to all of you sitting in front of
me now my friends at sepa for being my
family when mine was so far away and I
must recognize that I must thank my late
grandfather who was my inspiration I
liked run by Tommy on a survivor of the
armenian genocide and a man with so much
courage intellect and love for life that
i could only hope to emulate that in my
own lifetime class of 2010 you're the
best there ever was and the best sir
ever will be
this is the John Deere hat unlimited
supplies of red bull and two most
beautiful girls in the lobby keep it
classy and thank you again
congratulations and God sweet
now we have come slightly less swiftly
than I had imagined to the end of our
graduation ceremony just to remind you
again please remain seated first the
faculty and then the students will exit
family members will exit by different
doors you'll find each other outside
please try to stay off the street New
York drivers are terrifying in the short
time I have been privileged to serve as
dean of this grade school nothing has
impressed me more than the intelligence
idealism maturity and fearlessness of
Cephas extraordinary students I
congratulate you all on your success at
sepa and wish every one of you a life
made more rewarding and complete by the
joy of struggling for a better world I
look forward to seeing you tomorrow at
the University commencement and at the
recife reception that will follow it
congratulations sepa class of 2010
you